I love history,
and in K-12, you take history classes,
and a lot of kids are bored silly in them.
The history I learn is whenever I go someplace,
I want to know what happened each decade,
you know, for the last like 500 years before.
And I'm passionate about trends,
and what does that information about the past
tell you about the future
and how I can be part of the future
and shape the future
and bring people together
to do innovative things.
So, I'm passionate about knowing
where things have come from
and helping shape where they can go.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.